the Prime Minister and health secretary
have addressed the current NHS crisis
Steve Barkley says Hospital capacity
problems have been caused by patients
who do not need to be there but where
else are these pressures coming from
here you can see all 19 regions where
NHS trusts have declared critical
incidents in England during the last
week this is not normal even during a
very busy winter it shows what pressure
the NHS is under the biggest issue what
is driving this pressure is the lack of
social care for patients who are
medically fit to be discharged
there are over 12 000 people in hospital
that don't need to be there but can't be
discharged safely into the community
people are being urged to call 111
unless it's a real emergency in the week
before Christmas six hundred thousand
people call the service that's up over
two-thirds on the same period last year
and almost a third of callers abandoned
their calls before they were answered
and for patients trying to see their GP
there are also big delays despite
pledges by the government for 6 000 new
GPS by 2024 the number of fully trained
GPS has fallen by almost 2 000.
healthy to say these pressures are
driving up excess deaths not counting
the number of people who've died from
covid over the last six months there
have been an average of 800 extra debts
per week compared to the five-year
average in England and Wales Health
analysts say this is largely down to
delays in the NHS but NHS leaders and
the government dispute this
it's impossible to work out precisely
what makes up those 800 excess deaths
and there are many possible factors in
particular the consequences of the
pandemic the delayed treatment what you
might call you know the chronic delayed
care that people are you know have been
receiving it's quite plausible that
hundreds of those cases
um you know an estimate has been made
between three and five hundred and I I
think it's quite plausible that of that
sort of order of magnitude could be
attributable to the delays in people
getting into Hospital
the warnings of a triple democovid flu
and emergency department pressures have
been sounded for some time Health
leaders said this could be the worst
winter in the nhs's history and it looks
like those warnings might be coming true